ce sont des moments dangereux nous avons besoin de khan
le monde a besoin de lui
deux de ces monstres classiques s'affrontent
c'est vraiment tellement excitant
c'est un spectacle qui ne ressemble à rien de
ce que vous avez jamais vu mais la beauté de cette
histoire particulière réside dans les différents
scénarios  sur chaque personnage, il a besoin de
notre aide, il doit y avoir un moyen de
désorienter godzilla, vous pouvez regarder le
film comme deux histoires distinctes qui se
croisent finalement équipe kong et équipe
godzilla chaque histoire humaine suit également
l'histoire du monstre, nous
pensons qu'ils ont un ancien  rivalité les
mythes disent que leurs ancêtres se
sont battus dans une grande équipe de guerre khan vous
avez alexander skarsgard kaylee hoddle
et rebecca hall ils sont vraiment là pour
soutenir kong et son combat avec godzilla
les enjeux sont élevés et c'est une
opération très risquée mais nous  nous devons passer
par là,
matt dans le terrier du lapin
à l'autre bout du voyage, nous avons l'
équipe godzilla millie bobby brown brian
tyree henry et jillia  n dennison, ils sont
essentiellement dans cette aventure pour essayer de
découvrir pourquoi godzilla attaque, ils
essaient de mettre deux et deux ensemble pour
comprendre pourquoi cela se passe, ils sont
une équipe incroyable, ils se
complètent si bien pour être un  une partie de cette équipe
est géniale juste en essayant de comprendre
comment comprendre réellement godzilla plutôt
que d'essayer de le détruire
nous avons toujours vu le film comme étant
séparé entre l'équipe godzilla et l'équipe
kong et c'était excitant pour moi de faire
ce film
team con ou godzilla
i  je suis un gars de kung je ne sais pas j'ai une racine
pour kong difficile pour moi de choisir mais en tant que
personne japonaise
godzilla j'aime king kong parce que c'est un
singe géant et la voiture cool de l'équipe 100 du singe
je ne choisis pas ton camp
Je ne veux pas vraiment choisir un côté, je
dois choisir un côté, l'équipe va un peu
vite
toi